would also argue that you know there's a
lot of children sorry
i'll also argue there's a lot of other
things that women might break bringing
to the table just i mean let's say for
this discussion sake we're just assuming
that the man is more of a provider role
and the woman's a more stay-at-home
nurturing sort of role and
you know fair enough yeah if the if the
guy wants sex he's allowed to ask his
wife for that i think when we call it a
duty it is back to that word again it's
a little bit icky
granted yeah i was going to say that the
court system and the laws of the country
are still traditional but the society is
feminine is i'm sorry i'm feminist so in
that case like men will get charged more
women will get certain things but the
fact of the matter is if we are actually
living by this sort of feminist culture
where men and women are equal shouldn't
that come to the case with divorce as
well where it should be equal rather
than this sort of skewed old traditional
style which maybe was needed
maybe 50 80 100 years ago but it's not
relevant anymore
yeah yeah back to what paul was saying
before
the reason i don't like the way that the
court system works is because it
depletes a man this is what i was going
to say before but it depletes the man
and expects him to still be able to
provide and that doesn't make sense how
can a man that's depleted actually
provides
and for me especially when there's
you've got men who look after their
families extensively children i don't
know grandparents whatever that might be
it can be very very it's a fine thread
and we've spoken about this before
mental health well-being men being able
to express themselves freely and going
back to his point here with the feminine
society we consider women over all men
so their emotions the way they feel
about it like the word we're saying is a
bit icky but it's about that's a feeling
it's a feeling it's not
you know the tangibility in that
it doesn't translate so we get nitpicky
about how we feel about something and
everybody here
everybody hears us they hear us or we
say oh we don't like you know the guys
doing this and we don't like guys but i
mean just like yeah and then it's but it
strips back on the fact that you expect
a man to be a provider then you expect
him to be a man but you're stripping
back on his masculinity because i could
also say is is it a duty for a man to
provide for his family like what if he's
being what if he's being a bum and just
refusing what if he's what if he no but
that's what i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying but most people wouldn't say
that sounds icky right
if i say to a woman hey it's your duty
to have sex have like to be honest
that's easier than getting it like then
working 50 hours a week i mean
completely but i mean there's working in
this sex yeah but i mean it's it's not
to say like she just said if you're not
providing you're not having sex right
yeah so it's the same so if you're not
having sex the man ain't provided is
that nice
okay cool would you accept that this is
my finger
there's two things i want to say first
of all
the whole feminism stuff that you were
talking about this is why feminists
irritate me because you want to speak i
don't believe it's going to sound a bit
mad i don't believe in equality but i
believe in equity yeah okay i believe
that if if if you're earning five pounds
a day and someone's earning 50 pounds a
day and they're giving you a five and
you're thinking that's gonna suffice
that's not how it works that's not like
it doesn't make sense because
everybody's life is very subjective and
it's very different so equity is one
thing if women are out here screaming
equality equality equality and then
things happen and they're going into
courts now and they're coming from a
very emotional
standpoint which is closer to say their
nature and that is now their argument
you've basically gone against everything
we've just you've just protested against
right a and um what were we just
speaking about i just had a point um
well you basically said if he's not
providing he's not getting no sex and
then i said well if you spin it the
other way around if he's no sex and he's
not providing what do you think about
that let me tell you something here
most women
know what a man is and know how a man
should act but me like for example i'm
gonna use me forget everybody else i
know what a man is
but i will never go and step to man and
tell my man how to be do you understand
i know i know how a man is i know how
certain things need to be within a man
but i can never come and tell you you're
not a man or like this is what requires
you to be a real man
because i just feel like there's a
certain essence that needs to be
separated can i say something about the
difference there's equal weight like
you've got an equal weight over 10 000
kgs of rocks and 10 000 kgs of feathers
they're equal weight but they have
different qualities that feathers can be
blown away in the wind but the rocks is
still the same weight but it stands firm
that's the difference between the
masculine and femininity they've got
different attributes and they tremend to
be synergistic and work together so
question what do you mean by equity
so i believe that
if you see like for example say there's
a fence here
and
one person is six foot two and one
person is five foot and a quality would
be you get a box each and that would be
it and whoever if you get to see you get
to see and if you don't get to see you
don't get to see but you're equal
i believe in equity where if the six
foot two person needs one box and the
five-foot person needs free boxes for
them to spoof c that's equity for me so
so based on equity would you say that
women should be sleeping with more men
no i didn't but no but like let's sleep
with the short kings i think i think
equity i think meant anybody when it
comes to sex i think
today no equity come on
let me tell you something okay
if you want to do what you want to do do
what you want to do five foot and broke
i'm gonna tell you something equity the
reality but look i know a lot of let me
not even say it like that but i
have
interacted with a lot of women that will
have sexual relationships with a bomb
yeah but he's hot because he's calories
his game is amazing and they will stick
around and they will be on his air
mattress doing it all for two three
years
because they enjoy what they're getting
okay so so i'm gonna give you a couple
stats that might sway your view on this
so if you ask a hundred if you ask a
hundred percent of women what they want
in a guy they list twenty percent of men
women only swipe on between five to
fifteenish percent of men on dating apps
that one out of three men under 30 are
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year women are incredibly picky yes we
are but they have to be there's a
statistic that says um
there's
certain qualities and this is me very
loosely reiterating it there's qualities
within a man that only 40 of men
actually possess but 80 of women desire
so there's a there's a small bubble of
men that all these women are throwing
themselves at because they have all
these qualities and the rest are just
left but but what you said based on
equity we should be more inclusive
to make it to make it even i was
referring to in terms of the legality of
things in terms of the legalities and
stuff like that i don't believe that
like because we we were speaking about
the feminism and okay
i don't believe that should be can i
have an example of a law specifically
that would benefit like that supports
what you were talking about equity i
don't think there really is one
at the moment oh well that you would
advocate for um
because i'm just trying to understand
what you're talking about when you say
that because there's no real life
situation where we're on boxes with the
facts
if you have an example
chart support child support yeah yeah
okay so how would you do it
um i
hmm
i need to think about this because i
don't wanna yeah for starters
for starters we're not gonna take the
dad for a ride yeah you see what i'm
saying and let's say the mother might
have a bit to contribute herself they're
gonna they're gonna balance it to the
point where it makes sense for both
parties
so in the in the name
terms of maybe income because a lot of i
think a man should be or whoever whoever
messed up should be accountable and that
would be the catalyst to the child
support exactly and the whole
arrangement woman earns more than the
man yeah and also it wouldn't it
wouldn't default women as a custodial
parent it would observe the full
situation maybe
so and it can reduce the amount that the
man ends up paying or whatever it may be
or it could just completely avoid the
woman
so if there's a huge income disparity
would you still advocate in the name of
equity that the other parent gets it
no no because what do you mean because
again like i'm just thinking of the
boxes example yeah and in like in that
case the the guy that was super short
versus the guy that was really tall one
got one box the other got three so what
i'm thinking in the court system if
someone makes three times the amount of
money is the other
would you then take from one to give to
the other
and then like in the name of equity and
within the relationship no no i mean the
relationship's done oh so so explain it
to me so in in the box situation that
you gave me right
the short guy got more boxes in the name
of equity right yeah and so in this in
this case one one person makes three
times the amount the other person yes do
you take money from the person that
makes three times the amount and give it
to the other in the name of equity
i would say if the mat if the man she it
and and they divorced them that was
their reason and now he has to pay child
support if the woman earns three times
the amount i would rebuke the child
support
so so if the man cheats would you mean
rebuke then she doesn't have to pay
child support because he wouldn't have
to
he wouldn't have to because she earns
three times the amount i think it would
she have to pay him divorces would she
have to pay him no because she's not the
reason for their divorce
so but what about if it's do they just
divorce for no reason
then you split everything 50 50.
but i'm but i'm saying you can't split
everything 50 50 because they make three
times the amount as the other but i
think that that
the reason why i'm going to say that
changes within a marriage is because
when you come together you're unionized
you're two individuals that come
together so you know
before like when you're married to this
person this is the income x y right
if there's no real cause or it just
comes to a thing where you fizzle out
within your marriage and x y and z i
think agree upon assets agree upon what
she wants what he wants make it out to
it for it to be even
and go your separate ways and that
should be a personal thing i don't think
that should be something that so okay so
you would say
you would say that there shouldn't be
child support then
no that's not what i'm saying okay i'm
saying that
it's very circumstantial
if if if if you're say your ex partner
is on 25k a year
and you're on 100k
right and he
slept with somebody else i have now
divorced him as the wife mm-hmm i don't
but you don't know why he slept with
someone else like you could have not
been giving him sex personal matters
that's between you and your your partner
right so then shouldn't it not matter in
the divorce proceeding
well
shouldn't it not matter in the first
divorce proceeding why you guys divorced
yeah it would be it wouldn't though it
would just be unless it's something that
is saying you're saying it does matter
because you're saying if if he slept
with someone else then there's no
there's no child support even if the
girl makes more let me clear it up okay
yeah because y'all let's get into this
no i'm just trying to understand what
you're saying
what i'm saying is if my partner has now
cheated on me
and i have now filed filed for divorce
knowing that he owned he earns 20 25k a
year now and i'm on 100k a year first of
all me as a woman i wouldn't even want
your money but i just believe that it
doesn't make sense to now come and make
the man
pay uh 18 25 whatever it may be child
support when he was basically on minimum
wage what's the relevance of the
cheating then was he left foreign
why is it cheating that he usually could
just say she said she don't want to be
of him no more 100 but then there's
divorce yes i'm saying so the cheating
is not really relevant so if the
cheating is not relevant nothing should
be that side of things shouldn't be
relevant it's not relevant financially
don't forget you're a person of emotions
your partner is a person of emotions i'm
not saying you can't get divorced but
i'm saying in court yeah like don't you
think in court when we're talking about
money what happened in the bedroom
should like stay out of court yeah why
why is that right why does the judge
need to know this i think okay so so i'm
saying but like you were talking about
equity so
let's say the man makes three times what
the woman makes does he owe her any
money after like the divorce that's what
i'm asking
i would say for for if they have kids
yeah i would say why
because
it's not just this woman that you
like you are now
if this woman say she has sole custody
or majority custody of the child for
example you provide for your kids that's
50 of you do you know what i mean it's
not like this woman who you know is not
in any way shape or form or genetically
related to you
right now but it makes sense it just i
don't i don't agree because why because
why is she entitled to his money go get
a job
women leave women women women leave 70
to 80 of the time and in when they're
college educated 90 so why why are we
incentivizing women to leave we're
giving you a reward so you leave and you
get you get a check
the question is
saying so and so i'm saying as i work
right and i work really hard at what i
do and if i if i married a guy that made
three times what i make like i don't
think even if i have kids by him that
he's i'm entitled to his money
no you're not but your kids are yeah
right but so so shouldn't he shouldn't
he shouldn't he have the freedom to
spend like the money on the kid most
guys want so but why does so but in the
way that you're talking about it now
like you're saying that she's entitled
to his money i said your kids are
because your kids are literally fifteen
right but child support she gets so he
that's what i'm saying like shouldn't he
be able to spend the money she shouldn't
get it because that doesn't make sense i
think the only way that this can
actually make sense is if the court
actually has an impartial view when it
comes to deciding who takes custody of
the children because most of the time as
you know as we've said before when a
divorce happens they just give the
children to the mom they have to
actually investigate who's competent and
then the competent person gets to have
the children then they can decide
based on what a person let's say the
money that they make what kind of
contribution would be sensible to to be
put towards the care of the kids i mean
i think it should automatically be 50
50.
and then like i don't think there should
be an investigation unless there was
abuse
no but i feel like or drugs
yeah yeah i feel like there's many
reasons why people can divorce but i
think you know as you said there are
some circumstances where i would say it
does call for investigation
um like let's say for example you said
abuse would you would you agree that
that's the exception rather than the
rule
how do you mean would you agree that in
most cases people aren't abusive
oh so so so that's those cases
so in most cases it should just be 50
50. yeah but i would say
divorce the reason it's not 50 50 is
because money cannot be made if it's 50
50 then the woman doesn't get any money
because it's 50 50. so there's no money
to take from that because the court will
say boom the dad has the child 50 50 you
have it have the child 50 50. so then
you can't demand money because you both
equally have the children absolutely you
understand it's our business
but that's what i mean when i say they
should establish sort of like competency
if both parents are deemed fine
then of course i mean what would be the
reason for child support you get them
half the time yeah all the time
but the thing is it's business like i
said before on this show
for men they pay into the system women
are more likely to get legal aid they're
more likely to get provisions to support
them in a court case yeah men will take
their finances from their job or
whatever and have to pay to defend their
side of the story so it's a business for
the courts and for the women involved if
the if the court said boom everybody's
got 50 50 there is no court case yeah
because that that is the most valuable
asset but one of the things that you
that you you what you said that's
actually kind of made me think of
something is that that kind of whole
system sort of destroys the whole
traditional notion of a stay-at-home
mother and a working father because if
the woman let's say divorce is a man
she's automatically in a position where
she's not making any money and then the
court's just going to take her side you
see what i'm saying yeah but they're
probably going to help her why is she
doing she divorces she gets 50 50. she's
got half the time to earn some money bro
just like the man's got hope obviously
let's say if she was in a more
traditional role it's almost as if the
whole situation kind of
like
de-incentivizes
being traditional
because it's as soon as she let's say
leaves in a divorce she's in a position
where the courts will help her with
everything the the legal system from
going to court to do you see what i'm
saying and then it's like men are like
okay so he's saying she's not capable or
intellectual enough or has no skills i'm
saying get a good job saying that the
way the court automatically treats
providers
completely disincentivizes having a
traditional family structure having that
marriage because the man will lose his
stuff oh
okay yeah the man will lose his stuff
basically one thing pro can i just say
like they say this equality in equity if
he asks a woman do you want equality
with sex if you watch any like
clear-minded woman do you want to be as
we say in england a slag or a hole
they're saying no they don't want to go
sleeping around but if he asks a guy if
he wants to have his freedom to engage
with women it's like yeah i do actually
so these things sometimes don't relate
and most of the time these equities and
equalities they don't exist but they're
not